Mother Bear wakes up.
Her cub is missing.
She looks for her cub in the cave.
She cannot find him.
Mother Bear goes to Freddy Fox.
"Have you seen my cub?",...
...she asks.
"He is missing, and I am worried."
"No, I have not.",...
...says Mr. Fox.
Mother Bear goes to Doris Deer.
"Have you seen my cub?",...
...she asks.
"He is missing, and I am worried."
"No, I have not.",...
...says Ms. Deer.
Mother Bear goes to Rita Rabbit.
"Have you seen my cub?",...
...she asks.
"He is missing, and I am worried."
"No, I have not.",...
...says Mrs. Rabbit.
Mother Bear goes to Robert Raccoon.
"Have you seen my cub?",...
...she asks.
"He is missing, and I am worried."
"No, I have not.",...
...says Mr. Raccoon.
Mother Bear hears a bee buzzing.
"Have you seen my cub?",...
...she asks.
"Yes, I have.",...
...says the bee.
"And he is eating our honey."